The clothing tools that Unreal Engine 5 provides are actually inside of the animation tools,
particularly when you open up a Skeletal Mesh, there is an Activate and Deactivate Clothing Paint,
which allows you access to Unreal's cloth system.
Now, Unreal Engine uses the Chaos Cloth Solver, which is a low-level clothing solver responsible for the particle simulation that runs clothing.
This clothing solver allows integrations to be lightweight and is very extensible because we now have direct access to the simulation data.
Unreal's clothing tools are cross-platform enabled, and let's take a look at those tools in the editor now.
To access the tools, I do need to bring up a Skeletal Mesh, so I'm going to hit Control Space on the keyboard, and then click on Skeletal Meshes.
Inside the content examples, we do have a couple of clothing examples, so I'm just going to click one and open it up.
Now, once I have the Skeletal Mesh editor open, if I click on Activate Clothing Paint, this is where I will get the tools.
Once I click on this, you can see here I then have the ability to paint on this surface, and if we right-click on this and go to Set Target,
you can see here I have a bunch of different options for different settings for clothing circumstances, such as how the clothing will react when it teleports away from the user,
whether or not it should react to lift if it has drag and things like that.
There are also a number of different settings down inside of the tool under Cloth Can Figs.
We can adjust things like our mass or our density, as well as how this reacts to collision.
Justing the brush is actually done inside of the tool.
Down here at the bottom, we have this Clothing Tool, and we can click on this and change a brush, gradient, smooth, or fill, and then we can simply paint as we are used to.
Once we're done with this, we just need to simply close this and try that one more time.
There we go, and we will see the results there in real time in the editor.